i'm afraid it's very bad news for anyone
who wants to try and get a vaccination
in delhi or indeed throughout the
country it is not going well
at all most hospitals in the indian
capital do not have
enough stops of vaccines and are having
to delay
the actual rollout today they were
trying to extend it and had
said that they wanted to have 18 years
and older
to come and get vaccinated as a way of
trying to
stop this huge spike in the number of
cases they have set
global record highs in the number of
coronavares cases
for the last 10 days and another record
again today but most of the hospitals
not just in delhi
but throughout the country have said
they don't have the stocks
they're trying to put people off they're
trying to tell people don't come and
queue up
this is one of the rare vaccination
centers which has got
a small stop they've asked people to
book appointments on the app it's a
fraction
an absolutely tiny fraction they will
only be able to give
about 60 600
1200 vaccinations today in a city itself
which is made up of 17 million people
now a lot of people are asking how why
has a country which is the world's
biggest manufacturing vaccines
not have enough stock to vaccinate its
entire population
it has been shipping out since january
66 million doses to countries something
like
60 countries around the world on the day
that it hit
global record highs in corona rise cases
was april the 22nd that was the day that
it shipped out
even more to paraguay it's managed to
ship
out to bhutan for instance which has
totally vaccinated 93 of its population
within 16 days
and yet this country has not got its own
a lot of
a lot of the residents and the citizens
of india are asking
how has this happened was there too much
of a drive
to perhaps make money on the vaccines
and not
inoculate its own citizens these
scientists have been saying they warned
about this
several months back and right now
the people of india have been told they
might have to wait another
three weeks to get inoculated that's
less than
at the moment less than two percent of
the population here
are fully inoculated so a pretty dire
more grim news from india